my mom worked nine to six at the bank
and my dad worked three to twelve at the
shipyard it was all for us kids he just
worked so hard to make us happy that's
what I want for my daughters to be happy
they don't have any toddler size go on a
costume so I'm gonna try and make one of
my own for my daughter she's big into
Moana the other night she even woke up
asking for Moana I've got an old shirt
some fabric that I bought off of ebay I
got some velcro resistant piece just the
kids costume she won't even remember it
my wife Kate doesn't think I can do it
I'm gonna prove her wrong
[Music]
Flitz sleeping so obviously i can't put
these clothes on her that'd be weird and
it would wake her up and she'd be grumpy
so I'm gonna use my teddy bear Gundy who
I've had since I was five he's roughly
the size of Flynn it'll just give me an
idea of how it'll look on her then II
won't be embarrassed I'm sure
so Moana is dress is strapless but
that's probably not gonna work for a
toddler so I'm just gonna use this
drawstring that I pulled from an old
BuzzFeed hoodie okay doesn't think this
is gonna work I think it's coming
together
who's that what do you think get your
head okay just like a pillowcase it's
Sunday I went to the fabric store and
got more things to make the costume look
a little better I got some ribbon for
the top I got some new fabric for the
skirt and I got some buttons to make
putting on the top easier making this
Halloween costume for my daughter makes
me remember how my parents made
Halloween costumes for me when I was a
kid I remember when I was 8 my mom
hopefully make a Dick Tracy costume we
made the hat out of poster board when I
was 15 my dad made me Jedi robes my mom
worked 9 to 6 at the bank and my dad
worked 3 to 12 midnight at the shipyard
for them to take out that time means so
much more now that I understand I did
their best
they did their best to make me happy it
was all for us kids there are five of us
they just worked so hard to make us
happy that's what I want for my
daughters
I just hope it makes her happy hi can
you see me
say hi Lola look at doing the things for
my daughter that they did for me
makes me realize how much my parents
love me yeah like I knew they loved me
but I didn't understand how deep that
love was say bye-bye
noisy mom I'd wanna get it smiles ain't
it pretty good huh plus plus
[Music]